can we
talk about interactive proofs a little
bit and zero knowledge proofs
what are those okay how do they work so
interactive proof actually is um
is uh is a modern realization
and uh conceptualization of something
that
we knew was true but you know that is
easy to go to lecture
in fact that's my motivation we invented
schools to go to lecture and we don't
say oh i have the minister of education
i publish this book you read it
yeah invest this book for this year best
book for version
we spend a lot of our treasury in
educating our kids
and in person educating go to class
interact with a teacher on the
blackboard and chalk on my time
now we can have you know whiteboard and
presumably you're going to have actually
this
uh magic pens and a display instead
but the the the idea is that
interactively you can convey truth much
more efficiently
and we knew this psychologically it's
better to hear the explanation than just
to
be labor some paper right same thing
so interactive proofs is a way to to do
a following rather than doing in some
complicated very long
papers and possibly infinitely long
proofs exponentially long proofs
you say the following if this theorem is
true
there is a game that is associated to
the theorem
and if the theorem is true this game
i have a winning strategy that i can win
half of it
all the time no matter what you do
okay so then you say well is the theorem
true you believe me why should i believe
you so okay let's play
so and if i prove that i have a strategy
that
and i win the first time and i win the
second time then i lose a third time but
i win
every say more than half of a time or i
win
say all the time if serum is true and at
least at the most half of a time if the
theorem is false
you statistically get convinced you can
verify this
quickly and and therefore is a
much when the game in the game typically
is extremely fast
so you generate a miniature game in
which the theorem is true
i win all the time in the theorem is
false i can win at most
half of a time and if i win win win win
win win win you can deduce either the
firm is true
which most probably is the case of this
week
or i've been very very unlucky because
it's like if i had a hundred coin tosses
and i got a hundred heads
very improbable right so that is a way
and so this transformation
from the state formal statement of a
proof
into a game that can be quickly
played and you can draw statistics how
many times you win
and you is a is one of a
big conquest of a modern complexity
theory and in fact actually as a
highlighted
the notion of uh of a proof has really
given us a new insight to what
to be true means and what what the truth
is and what
proofs are so these are generally proofs
so what kind of
mysteries can it allow us to unlock
and improve you said truth
so what does it allow us what kind of
truth does that allow us to arrive at
so it enlarges the real mobot is
provable because
in some sense of the classical way of
proving things
was extremely in inefficient
from the very fire point of view yes
right so
and and so therefore there is so much
proof that you can take
and but in this way you can actually
very quickly minutes
verify something that is
the correctness of our assertion that
otherwise would have taken our lifetime
to belabor and check all the the
passages of a very very long proof
and you better check all of them because
if you don't check one line
an error can be in that line and so you
have to go linearly through all the
stuff
rather than bypass this so you enlarge
tremendous amount
what the proof is and in addition
uh once you have the idea that
essentially a proof system is something
that
allows me to convince you of a true
statement
but does not allow me to convince you of
a false statement
and beta at the end says if it's a proof
proof can be beautiful
should be should be elegant but advances
is
true or false so he wants to be able to
differentiate it is possible to prove
the truth
and it should be impossible or
statistically extremely hard
to prove something false and if you do
this you can prove way way more once you
understand this
and on top of it we got
some insight i can visit zero knowledge
proofs that is in
something which you took for granted
were the same
knowledge and verification are actually
separate concepts
so you can verify that an assertion is
correct
without having any idea why this is so
and so people fail to say if you want to
verify
something you have to to have a proof
once you have a proof you know why it's
true you have
the proof itself and so somehow you can
totally differentiate knowledge
and and uh and verification validity so
totally you can
decide if something is true and still
they have no idea is there a good
example
in your mind oh actually
you know at the beginning we labored to
find the first knowledge
zero knowledge proof then we found a
second when we found the third
and then a few years later actually we
proved a theorem
which essentially says every theorem no
matter what about
can be explained in a zero-knowledge way
okay so it's not a class of fear but
all theorems and is a very powerful
thing so if we were really
for thousands of years
bought this identity between knowledge
and verification
to be hand in hand together and uh for
no reason at all
i mean we had to develop a weaver
technology as you know i'm very big on
technology because
it makes us more human and and make us
understand
more things than before and and i think
of it is a
that is a that's a good thing
you